hey uh SE V uh this is Riley and uh
what's up
Riley let's hear more baby do it so
recently at my middle school there's
this new kid that's Transit what the
[__] is middle middle
school middle
school what am I thinking of Middle
School like a what um okay uh yep yep
let's sorry let's hear more
man this new kid that's Transit over the
years it's a new
year and all right so he's cool and
stuff all right uh I know this uh might
be offensive I don't know no offense oh
it's fine but is
uh yeah he's a big black kid
and I I paid him
$3 to know my friend
to like mess with my friend okay so you
paid a brother $3 a mess with your
friend okay we got it I think that's
called what is that
called I don't know let's hear
more and guess what he does he slapped
him and he kept on requesting more and
more money and he keeps on trying to get
me send them more money and I don't
really know what to
do dang homie you that's what see look
man if you start a $3 brother dog you
don't you know what I'm saying you can't
you can't ask for you can't be expecting
$5
Behavior if you you know what I'm saying
you can't even be expecting $10 Behavior
out of $3 brother or any $3 Hitman man
so I think you got to you got to you got
to top him off with the extra that money
i' get him another seven say look this
[__] ends here Daddy this [__] ends here
cuz if he slapped him damn bro you
involved in damn crime brother you in
damn crime homie God damn brother yeah
that's look I've been there you start a
couple dollar brother on some low-key
crime and then you can't [__]
stop he want us to you know cuz sometime
people get motivated a little bit it
doesn't matter what the Avenue is
whether it's uh you know for the good or
the bad
you know in these days crime half of our
government is crime so hell that dude
could be a damn mayor in six months but
God baby yeah seven you I say you hit
him with that seven bucks
man
uh let me I might even pay it off for
you man because I don't want you getting
involved in some [__] I don't want you
getting too deep and [__] you still too
young man for that God damn brother oh
yeah I remember I lent a dude 8 some
dude with no [__] shoes
and he bought a bunch of dope and I had
to go down to his [__] family and
their door was inoperable or something
some of the and you had to go in and out
right through their [__] window by
the sink you had to [__] climb up
this plant pot and get in there I was so
scared dude and they were in there
[__] they had a cat that was dying
and they were in there bottle feeding
it and I was like I do not need my 8
I am getting the [__] out of this
[__]
so